so what's the relationship with Mitch
and Trump at this point we know that
it's all strained even like
establishment Republicans whether it's a
a Romney or a a pence or a mitch you
know these establishment Republicans
where are they with Trump these days
Mitch specifically though I know I think
I think the relations are there's a cold
war between Mitch and Trump and partly
it's the Trump calls Mitch like you
broke an Old Crow and names like that
and I don't think you should do that to
be honest but he does do that he ain't
the only one Dinesh that's getting a
nickname from Trump yeah so he does that
stuff and then Mitch you know Mitch is
an old establishment guy and I don't
think he likes it and he's uh so there
there's a very uneasy relationship there
who do you think has more power within
government within like the actual
senators and representatives a McConnell
or McConnell McConnell McConnell has
more power on the legislative process
but to be honest Trump has far more
power with the base with the people yeah
with the people of course so if if Trump
does get reelected right I mean we're
fast forwarding how's that relationship
going to work because it's so beyond
strained at this point assuming
McConnell's still there in the Senate at
some level I mean look they're similar
he might be the Senate Majority Leader
if they take it over in 2022 next week
yeah there's there are
um there are similar strains on the
Democratic side they're not as obvious
the media doesn't cover them the truth
of it is both parties can function with
some levels of strains because they're
United by you know philosophy uh less
government and
um more personal Liberty and you know
and they're United also by their
hostility to the other party and the bad
stuff that comes out of the other side
so to me it's not impossible that Trump
and McConnell could work together
although I think that there is likely to
be at some point a movement to challenge
McConnell in part because McConnell is
also getting really old right but there
it's way more strained on the right
meaning like the mid McConnell and Trump
situation is way worse than like a
Schumer Pelosi Biden situation I don't
even think it's terrible right yeah
that's right that is right yeah I
brought up McConnell simply because
that's the narrative that that
that sliver of the Republican party that
is over Trump by their own words not by
my accusation by their own words is
there but where in the Republican Party
are those people that would like to see
an investigation simply to do what
you're saying hey let's go count it
let's let law enforcement dive in let's
go look at the data and let's all sit
back and get away from the microphone
and and posturing and hypothesizing and
let's look at data who in the Republican
Party
is is with you to say hey let's go look
at this and if the date is credible
let's show it so that would be by and
large the people in the so-called Mago
make America great again wing of the
Republican Party classic example would
be right now I think it's possible that
all the four major candidates in Arizona
will win uh it could be three maybe
Blake Masters will lose to Mark Kelly
but I think Kerry Lake will win
um her race of Mark comedy will win for
attorney general Mark fincham for
secretary of state so all those guys are
major Advocates of 2000 meals they came
to our screening they've talked up the
movie so those this is the kind of new
face of the Republican party that will
be like we need to have an investigation
we need to have hearings now admittedly
Carrie licks running for governor she's
not running for Senator for congress but
that's the sensibility we're talking
about so it's the Lauren bobert's and
stuff that are on the Congressional side
yes but it's also it's not just that
it's also people who are more to the
mainstream I mean I've had Steve scalise
in my podcast guys he's concerned Tom
Cotton people like that who have power
in the Republican party but are not
necessarily right now in leadership
within the Republican Party do you kind
of have to pick a side I'm a Maga guy or
I'm just a traditional Republican like
how does that break down and where do
you fall in line there so what's
happening in the Republican party is you
know think of how strange it is you know
when I came to America in 1978 the the
left and the right were quite different
than they are today if you met a leftist
on a campus I was a Dartmouth I met a
lot of leftists for the first time here
were their biggest shoes you know number
one they were Defenders of minorities in
the working class number two they care
about individual civil liberties
um and this applied from everything to
free speech to abortion like get the
government off my back let my
individuality flourish and number three
they were against the Cold War they were
against War they were the peace party
so just take those three things right
now and they flipped on their head in 78
right 78 to six years after Vietnam yeah
six years after Vietnam it's fresh it's
fresh and now the you talk to the left
about the working class they're like oh
yeah look there's a bunch of morons so
those guys are a bunch of truck drivers
and bums you know make them wear their
masks you know so there's a hostility to
the working class no surprise the
working class is pushing toward the
Republican Party number two civil
liberties I mean the biggest issue of
civil liberties is an abortion it's can
you speak your mind I mean can you just
talk uh and on all these key platforms
the left has become the party of
censorship not just the leadership the
ordinary Democrat wants to shut you down
and shut your speech off and allow
speech to be regulated by the big Tech
platforms if possible but if they won't
do it by the government and there's all
kinds of survey data to support that and
number three suddenly the left has
become their pro-fbi the pro CIA and the
pro war I mean they're even saying
things like you know we we if Biden
talks about World War III they're on
board so think of the change that's
occurred there there's a similar change
occurring on the Republican side a party
that's becoming you know somewhat more
working class I mean when I was in when
I was in college if you met a guy who's
a CEO of a company that was an 80 chance
that guy's a republican now there's an
80 chance that guy's a Democrat so so no
wonder the the old Republican guard is
used to relying on the business guy the
you know the oil guy the Chamber of
Commerce guy that's their team and
suddenly those guys are being challenged
and all these new people are coming in
so that's what that is what's going on
in the ground and and Maga and the
establishment are just metaphors for
this really big sweeping change
occurring at the ground level so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign
[Music]